vous voulez acheter une à punch et vous
avez raison sont de très jolis monte
mais vous ne savez pas quel apple voit
qu'il a achetée en 2022 alors je vais
venir ici vous aider on va tous des gros
si on va regarder quel appel aux
architectes si vous regardez sur le site
d'apple vous avez 3 apple walsh qui
reste au catalogue et vous avez là paul
walsh série 7 la s e et la série 3 alors
est-ce qu'il faut acheter une de ces
trois mondes peut-être oui mais pas
toutes on va donc se décanter tout ça
regardez point par point on va regarder
qu'elle montre est fait pour vous pour
quels usages pour le sport pour la santé
pour la famille pour la mémé pour les
parents on va tous regarder tout ça tout
de suite c'est parti pour savoir quel
apple watch acheté en 2022 et ça s'est
super bien
[Musique]
et auquel on y va alors pour savoir
qu'elle appellerait de s'acheter on a
besoin de quoi en a besoin d'une feuille
on a besoin d'un crayon si le crayon
marche plus on a un deuxième crayon bref
en équipe et alors on va regarder ici
4004 nôtres qui sont intéressantes on va
regarder l'apple watch service est ça
qui a été présentée en 2021 on va
regarder l'apple watch série 6 qui était
présenté en 2020 bien évidemment on va
regarder là et ceux là et ce qui a
également été présenté en 2020 qui est
toujours au catalogue d'ailleurs et puis
la paloise series 3 qui a été présenté
il ya tellement longtemps qu'on l'a
oublié mais elle est toujours présente
au catalogue d'apple alors on va
regarder plusieurs points pour savoir si
ces mondes sont intéressantes et puis on
va regarder les prix parce que si vous
regardez là cette écoute quand même 429
euros à partir 2 429 euros parce qu'il
existe une version uniquement wifi ou
une version cellulaire ici on se base
sur le plus petit modèle à partir de 429
euros pour la série 6 est bien n'existe
plus on la trouve plus rien ou d'apple
mais on pouvait trouver à partir de 429
euros on peut la trouver aujourd'hui à
309 euros il reste des stocks fut certes
un retailer on peut le faire on peut le
voir donc pourquoi pas ça peut être
intéressant ou encore en reconditionnant
avoir la sll et à 299 euros et ben ouais
ça fait quand même une sacrée différence
entre 4 129 et 199 ans vous me direz
entre l'a6 à 309 me la s e soit 99 vous
allez sur l'a6 si vous le trouvez ce
prix là à boire qu'on va regarder ça et
puis elle a 3 alors la trois est
carrément à 219 euros ok voilà on a donc
aujourd'hui quatre modèles quatre
modèles qu'on va venir regarder mais on
va commencer tout de suite on va y aller
à grands coups de hache pour savoir quel
modèle il faut supprimer je vous le dit
franco de biais on va supprimer la 3
pourquoi non pas que la 3 soit un modèle
qui n'était pas sympathique mais c'était
il ya tellement longtemps qu'on a oublié
d'ailleurs auquel année elle est sortie
la 3è gamin petit écran elle a pas
énormément de performance et si vous
achetez une montre aujourd'hui en 2022
il a gardé en 2023/2024 voire plus si
affinités et arrivera un moment où les
mises à jour ça va être une telle
catastrophe que vous ne pourrez plus
donc aujourd'hui la 3 vous l'oubliez
même si elle rend service même si elle
vous permet de rentrer aujourd'hui est
bien dans l'écosystème d'apple au
travers de la monde connecté si vous
avez un iphone et qu'il vous faut une
monde connecté je pense je vous le
conseille économiser un petit peu plus
mais achetez vous une est ce parce
qu'elle a quasiment tous des grands on
va réaliser dans quelques instants donc
la 3 c'est pas la même que j'admire vous
recommander non pas parce qu'en 2022
allait pas bien mais parce qu'on 2023
sera pas le dernier en 2024 elle le sera
encore moins et ne parlons pas de 2025
et une montre on l'apprend c'est pour la
garde et on est là pour garder les
produits la journée le plus loin dans le
temps ok donc là maintenant il nous
reste trois mondes principal on à la 7
on à la 6 et on a là et ce alors on va
se dire ok ok ok je sais pas si vous
avez regardé ma vidéo test de l'a7
l'année dernière elle est très proche de
là est ce vraiment très proches que
quelques petits points de différence
alors on va regarder différents pensant
dans les différents points on va d'abord
regarder la question de la taille et ben
ouais parce que la taille c'est
important parce que les formats sont pas
les mais alors née voilà sept elle est
intéressant pourquoi et bien parce
qu'elle a un écran qui est un peu plus
grand on a ici une montre qui va être en
41 ou en 45 mm elle va être un peu plus
grande que la six qui elle était en 40
ou en 44 mm c'est d'ailleurs la même
taille l'a6 et la s e ça c'est pour la 7
allez hop la danse est une petite
séparation c'est beau c'est bien fait
donc on va voir une montre qui est un
poil plus grande et puis surtout un
écran un peu plus grand et un écran qui
en veste et la première fois cap à
nouveau un écran incurvé donc si vous
voulez une montre assez grande le plus
grand qu'on puisse trouver et bien là
cette sans aucun doute c'est la plus
grande pour autant on est très proche de
la six est très proche de la hesse la
grosse différence qu'on va retrouver
avec l'a6 et l'a10 au niveau de la
taille est bien c'est qu'on n'aura pas
un écran incurvé common avec l'a7 on
aura des bords qui seront un peu plus
gros des bords plus fin avec la cette
mise à part ça c'est la même chose et
puis il ya un autre point intéressant si
vous avez déjà une apple watch et que
vous avez déjà une collection de
bracelets et bien vos bracelets seront
compatibles avec l'a6 l'a7 la haye ce
bref ils sont totalement compatibles
donc vous allez pouvoir continuer à être
cocus ou coquette avec vos bracelets
sans problème et ça aussi c'est dire
alors une fois qu'on a résolu la
question de la taille on va se poser la
question à faire de vos besoins bah oui
parce que les besoins c'est quand même
vachement important qu'est ce que vous
allez venir en faire pourquoi une apple
watch alors bien évidemment pour avoir
eu monde connecté qui va marcher avec
votre iphone pour pouvoir lire vos sms
répondre aux sms vocalement pour pouvoir
accéder à ses applications pour pouvoir
a payé actuellement avec apple pie pour
beaucoup de choses mais au-delà de ça
pourquoi on va aller sur une apple watts
spécifiquement ou une autre et c'est là
où on a séparé des usages et c'est là où
c'est vachement intéressant alors pour
moi je vais bien voir plusieurs usages
on va déjà voir l'usagé un petit peu je
dirait monsieur et madame tout le monde
ok alors je vais marquer monsieur slash
madame tout le monde vous saurez à quoi
on fait référence ici et bien qu'est ce
que veulent faire monsieur madame tout
le monde des glaces et tous ces usages
liés à une monde connecté que je viens
de vous décrire très simplement on se
dira que n'importe quel apple watch le
fera là on pourrait dire l'a3 ok sauf
que là 3 commencera un petit peu a ramé
puis des mises à jour je vous dise avec
guerre dans les années à venir donc on
oublie la 3 donc à partir de là est ce
la 6 et l'a7 ça fonctionnera pour tout
le monde c'est la base de la base ok
donc ça c'est bien ça ça me rassure en
suisse qui va intéresser bien bien c'est
le sport puisqu'une monde connecté on va
la garder au poignet pour aller faire du
sport donc on à l'usagé ce port qui est
aussi un usage très important et ça
c'est cool alors que tu saches porte je
dirais qu'on aura sensiblement le même
entre l'a6 l'a7 et là est ce pourquoi
parce qu'on aura quasiment les mêmes
capte quasiment pas tout à fait il ya
des capteurs qu'on aura en moins on va
pouvoir retrouver au niveau de l'assise
et de l'a7 et qu'on n'aura pas au niveau
de la est ce ça va être le capteur de
saturation d'oxygène de votre sang et la
possibilité de faire un
électrocardiogramme bon ok alors pour le
sport la saturation en oxygène dans le
sang j'ai envie de vous dire pourquoi
pas mais c'est plus de la santé et puis
le cgc de la santé donc pour le sport en
gros on peut venir se prendre ici est
bien là et ce on peut se prendre l'a6 on
peut se prendre là c'est pareil pour
monsieur et madame tout le monde après
c'est une question d'argent clairement
ici donc on voit qu'en fait que ce soit
l'une l'autre ou encore la troisième
pour le sport il n'ya pas de soucis
alors je vous parlais de la santé il ya
quelques instants et c'est aussi en
train qui est extrêmement important et
là ça devient un peu différents à savoir
que effectivement et comme je vous le
disais au niveau de la est ce vous
n'avez pas le capteur de saturation
d'oxygène du sang et vous n'avez pas non
plus la possibilité de faire un
électrocardiogramme pour autant si vous
souffrez d'une pathologie il faut savoir
que votre apple watch ce n'est pas un
dispositif médical elle vous permettra
d'avoir un suivi d'avoir des données de
santé mais si les choses qui vous
paraissent anormal au niveau d'autres
apeloig qu'il vous faut un appareil
médical et surtout aller consulter un
spécialiste pour vraiment faire un point
et voir ce qu'il en est alors c'est vrai
que c'est intéressant parce qu'il a un
côté un peu rassurant elle a tout le
temps au poignet on peut voir aussi si
on a une arythmie mais çà et là est ce
que vous le voyez aussi si vous avez une
arythmie les capteurs seront deux
générations supérieur l'a6 et l'a7
versus là et se met pour autant en
termes de données de santé c'est sur
clément qui seront les plus
intéressantes se seront 6la 7 mai pour
autant là et ce n'est pas aux fraises
vous allez pouvoir voir votre rythme
cardiaque on va voir si vous avez une
heure et demie mais ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'au niveau de la santé l'a6 et l'a7
sont très bonne donc si vous trouvez
encore une 6 pas trop cher ou en
reconditionnés ça vaut pas laisser ça
manque ou d'aller sur l'a7 l'a7 a dit
bénéfices bouddhiste écran incurvé
banques et pas mal de petites choses qui
donnent chose qu'on va voir dans
quelques instants mais c'est vrai que
l'a6 reste très actuel et qu'il n'ya pas
réellement de grosses différences en
termes d'usagé entre l'a6 et entre l'ass
est donc pour la santé bon ok on peut
aussi aller sur l'ice eux on ira un peu
moins loin ça dépend de vos besoins en
matière de santé mais ça une fois de
plus c'est à vous de voir après il ya un
autre truc qui est intéressant c'est
bien je dirais pour les technophiles
alors là c'est plutôt un usage mais
c'est en fait le fait de se dire bah moi
ce que je veux c est la montre la plus
connectée je veux c'est le cas le
maximum de performance je veux le truc
le plus cool et bien à ce moment-là
qu'est ce qu'il vous faut la sete on se
pose pas de questions vous avez bien
évidemment cet écran incurvé vous avez
de la recharge qui va être entre 3 %
plus rapide ça va beaucoup plus vite
vous avez de la recharge en plus si on
usb c'est ça va plus vite c'est plus
simple et c'est pour moi de gros
bénéfices qu'on à capello h série 7 vous
la prenez vos la charge est une des
meilleures et vous êtes repartis donc si
vous aimez dormir avec votre montre et
bien vous faites ça vous la prenez vous
la charge et vous pouvez dormir vous
l'avez jour et nuit avec vous pour venir
tout monitorer votre sommeil et
compagnie c'est intéressant là si ça ira
moins vite vous allez à charge et
beaucoup moins vite il faudra un peu
plus de temps pour autant l'autonomie
c'est exactement la main que ce soit là
est ce que ce soit la cise que ce soit
là cet essai un autre point qui nous
intéresse ici est bien c'est la question
de l'autonomie est bien ici vous avez
une journée d'autonomie vous n'avez pas
plus pas moins que toutes les montres la
seule qui va être intéressante ça va
être là c'est parce qu'elle a une charge
extrêmement rapide aux plats avec des
petits plus donc ça c'est très très cool
je voulais donc si vous êtes
technophiles et que vous voulez ce qui
est mieux vous allez sur l'a7 mais par
contre vous allez le payer parce que la
montat coûte quand même à partir de 429
euros donc voila un petit peu pour
l'idée ici alors appris à la notion de
la performance qui est aussi un point
qui est extrêmement important je prends
des feuilles j'ai plus de place alors la
performance qu'est ce que ça raconte ici
et bien en fait plus vous allez avancées
au niveau de vos montres dans les années
et plus elles vont être performante
exactement la même chose au niveau de
vos iphone alors c'est quand même vous
notez pour la 3 on était sur le s3 assez
logique là est ce on était sur la s5
l'a6 on est sur l'a6 et l'a7 où il donne
dans l'île sur la s est ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que vous avez un gap
de performances souvent c'est les
performances de l'ordre de 20 à 30 %
donc là vous allez avoir une différence
de 20 à 30% entre l'a6 et l'a7 mais pour
autant vous sentirez quasiment pas et ça
ira extrêmement bien donc pas de soucis
ici vous allez avoir une plus grosse
différence entre la set et là et se met
pour autant ça fonctionnera lie ce reste
très très actuel et je peux vraiment
vouloir commander maintenant pour moi la
trois et c'est pour ça que je vous dis
qu'elle est ou serait ce qu'en termes de
performance et bien ça va ramer ça ne
marche pas parce que vous avez quand
même ici quelque chose qui va être
beaucoup plan et qui forcément va vous
faire vous arracher les cheveux en
termes de performances on oublie ça mais
et n'oubliez pas je vous le dis une fois
de plus cela est ce elle reste très très
très actuelle est elle marchera
parfaitement bien et puis après il ya
des petits trucs en plus ce qu'il faut
savoir et qui sont aussi intéressantes
c'est que par exemple voyez ma série 7
et bien elle a une certification qui est
hyper 6x elle va être résistantes à la
poussière mais pour autant toutes les
autres montres sont résistantes à l'eau
donc vous pouvez allez vous baigner elle
est fabula de natation avec sans aucun
problème dès lors vous avez le bracelet
adaptés ne mettait pas un bracelet en
cuir pour aller faire un mode 50 m dans
la piscine ça n'irait pas mais vous
pouvez faire ce que vous voulez donc on
dévoie terme d'étanchéité on avait
vraiment ce qu'il faut donc là on a une
petite certification en plus on va avoir
un verre aussi également qui va être un
peu plus résistant au niveau de l'ass
est ok ça changera pas la face de
l'histoire mais de toute façon et ce qui
peut être intéressant si vous avez des
métiers à risques c'est venir protéger
votre montre avec quoi et bien la
protection de nos partenaires et nos
chine parce que oui aujourd'hui c'est
une vidéo qui est réalisé en partenariat
avec rhino chine vous en douterez parce
que vous avez des protections chéri
nocher qui vont venir protéger votre
monde contre tous les chocs presque tous
en tout cas regardez ça vient le protégé
l'avant protection contre les chocs et
un design personnalisable on peut venir
changer les couleurs la couleur
intérieure et la couleur extérieure 100%
sans bpa vous avez donc plein de
couleurs on peut bien la personnaliser
personnaliser votre set et votre grand
concours extérieurs et après vous avez
une bordure additionnel pouvait faire
des choses un petit peu bizarre comme ça
un peu atypique vous pouvez faire match
est totalement ici à la couleur de votre
bracelet et ça c'est cool vous l'avez
pour la série 7 voulait pour la haye ce
boulet pour la série 6 si vous avez des
mondes générations antérieures et que
vous souhaitez conserver pourquoi pas
donner un ami ou revendre vous pouvez
avoir aussi et bien vos protections de
rhinau chiffres sont les crasses garde
enix pour apple watch compatible avec
tous les bracelets apple on va avoir
toutes les couleurs qu'on veut
protection contre les chocs conforme aux
standards militaires donc là aussi on
rassurée elle pichéry nos chiffres vous
avez également des coques de protection
pour votre iphone oui si vous avez un
peu mois que j'ai probablement un iphone
y en a dans tous les univers il ya plein
de collaboration se demande alors y
alger de esport disney classics dragon
ball badman france ruby van gogh museum
marvel stars wars disney mickey disney
pixar harry potter grenadois je vous le
passez il y en a tellement league of
legends le ps je vous en passe et des
meilleures si vous voulez acheter une
protection pour votre apple watchou une
coque par votre iphone vous avez 5 % de
remise avec le code greu 22 je vous ai
mis le lien en bas dans la description
pour cliquer dessus comme ça vous
achetez vos protections au meilleur prix
et ça c'est cool et merci à rhinau chic
d'avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo et puis
il ya un autre point qui est essentielle
et qui vachement intéressant qui vous
décidera peut-être à ne pas aller sur la
3 mais allez sur les autres est bien
c'est que vous avez la possibilité
d'avoir une configuration familiale ça
c'est cool déjà si vous êtes parent et
que vous avez des enfants et que vous
voulez acheter des mondes pour vos
enfants et bien vous allez pouvoir venir
ici les configurer pour toute la famille
uniquement sur la s e l'a6 et l'a7 il ya
un autre point qui est très rassurant si
vous voulez acheter une apple watch
monde vos parents pour vos seniors qui
ont des risques de chute eh bien vous
avez sur la s e l'a6 et l'a7 la
détection de chute que vous n'avez pas
sur la série 3 est ce qui la rend encore
plus obsolète donc je dirais et c'est là
où on revient sur la question des tarifs
si vous avez l'argent si vous avez le
budget vous avez une apple world series
7 à partir de 429 euros dans la finition
aluminium pas vraiment dans les
finitions lui en voulez d'autres
finition titane bon je vous passe un peu
ça c'est vraiment si vous êtes beaucoup
d'argent et vous voulez mettre beaucoup
d'argent dans votre monde les mêmes une
série hier mais ça c'est encore autre
chose qu'à partir de 429 euros vous avez
les moyens vous voulez la meilleure
apple watch avec les meilleures
finitions vous avez la série 7 qui est
très cool 429 euros si maintenant vous
avez un tout petit peu moins de budget
mais voulait comme une apple ou h avec
tous les derniers capteurs le capteur
saturation en oxygène que vous voulez
pouvoir faire un ecg vous pouvez
retrouver une apple walsh série 6 soit
en reconditionnés soi-même 9 pour
certains magasins il ya encore des
stocks à partir 309 euros sur le 40 mm
donc ça c'est aussi très très bien on va
se dire que c'est ce que trop une apple
walsh et réussissent à 309 euros
pourquoi est ce que j'irai m'acheter une
nouvelle ce à la 10 euros d'écart il n'y
a pas d'intérêt alors je suis d'accord
avec vous si vous la trouvez encore
celle-là en oeuvre à 309 euros vous
n'allez pas sur une us mais si vous la
trouvez pas si elle est pas dans le
commerce aussi les finitions nous
plaisent pas là et ce pour moi elle est
extrêmement canon j'ai vraiment retenir
deux gros modèles je vais venir retenir
l'a7 vous avez les moyens vous laisse
qui se fait mieux vous prenez la 7 si
vous avez un peu moins les moyens et bas
soit vous ne trouvez encore la 600
revendeurs en neuf à 309 euros ou alors
vous allez sur la haye ce qui est
extrêmement canon qui en fera un petit
peu moins mais qui est vraiment une très
très très joliment
voilà il faut donc que vous connaissiez
vos usages sport passeport santé pas
santé et puis après on a bien maîtrisé
son u2 sont vraiment les points
essentiels dans tous les cas et ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que l'appel soit une
excellente montée connectez vous à
pouvoir faire beaucoup de choses avec
webos c'est très pratique moi je les ai
tout le temps il ne serait ce que veut
dire déverrouiller son iphone avec son
apple watch avec un mass eh bien on peut
le faire et c'est pour moi aussi un des
gros aux usages un des gros points forts
qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui avec cet
appel watch vous avez le combo apple
watch iphone ça marche très bien et y un
super beau travail qu'a fait apple la
suite tout en sachant que si vous
achetez une apple watch aujourd'hui en
2022 vous bénéficierez des mises à jour
de webos qui seront présentés cette
année au dab et louis zabel ou dc
probablement en juin 2022 mais ça c'est
une autre histoire on en reparlera
ultérieurement donc vous invite à venir
vous abonner pour tout savoir sur
l'actualité pour tout savoir sur la
nouveauté d'apple mais pas que et si
vous avez des idées conseils suggestions
pour choisir une apple watch pour elle
marque est bien évidemment en
commentaire vous avez des questions vous
pouvez également les marques et aux
commentaires et nous on retrouve très
vite pour continuer d évidemment à part
les tec parler d'apple zappa watch &
company donc ça c'est bien vous embrasse
à bientôt ciao prenez soin de vous des
bibelots
[Musique]